did you know selling homemade tamali is
illegal in some states believe it or not
Arizona doesn't allow the sale of
homemade tamales in 20203 Arizona was
about to pass a bill that would have
legalized the sale of homemade Goods
containing perishable ingredients but
Governor Katie Hobbs vetoed it citing an
increase in the risk of foodborn illness
and rodent or insect infestation please
consider that foodborn illness outbreaks
are far more likely to come from
restaurants than homes and they are
relatively rare Banning the sale of
certain kind of homemade food
overwhelmingly hurts women and
immigrants who are the majority of these
Cottage food producers making their
goods at home some of them have even
been fined and arrested for selling
homemade food one example is a woman
from Carolton Texas being mailed a
warrant arrest notice and ultimately
being fined $700 what are your thoughts
do you think selling homemade Tami
should be illegal